moi
et
il existe un gilbert bécaud secret
celui qui a écrit cette grande classique
à l'âge de ses études musicales
celui qui aujourd'hui composé un opéra
mais alors gilbert bécaud qui êtes vous
parce qu'avant d'être gilbert bécaud je
travaille énormément vous comprenez je
mes parents se sont donné beaucoup de
mal pour me pour m'apprendre la musique
je connais la musique je connais mon
métier va comprenait deux musiciens et
alors ce n'est pas parce que peu
beaucoup de gens par exemple même pas
gilbert bécaud en tant que chanteur que
cela a un rapport avec l'autre je suis
deux je voudrais qu'on me laisse de vous
comprenez pas ce qu'il y'a j avais coup
sur la scène ça c'est un personnage
c'est quelqu'un qui écrit les clans sont
les chants des mais s y en a un autre
aussi quand même alors dites-moi gibert
décoiffe trente trois ans et alors que
vous êtes s'élève à quoi ça correspond
d'un team de profondes commencé d'écrire
à l'opéra eh bien ça correspond à tout
pour moi ça correspond au fait que
je ne chanterai pas toujours quand on
est je ne chanterai pas toujours d'une
part et d'autre pas que avant de tout si
je chante c'est parce que j'écris des
chansons comme on est alors l'opéra
correspond pour moi un retour à mes mon
travail je n'étais pas destiné à chanter
ni écrire des chansons j'étais destiné à
la musique
vous savez je suis un musicien il n'y a
pas de mauvaise musique il n'ya que de
mauvais musicien
vous êtes l'une des premières vedette de
music hall peut-être la première et ça
ne vous suffit pas vous aspirer à autre
chose et je ne suis pas je suis une v2
music hall parce que le public a voulu
que j'en sois une jeu j'en suis ravie
d'ailleurs je suis très très très
content et très fier et je fais mon
travail très bien et j'adore chanter
j'aime et c'est ma vie mais ma vie aussi
et écrire une chose que
j'ai envie d j'ai un tas de choses à
dire et j'ai bien peur de ne pas arriver
au bout de tout ce que j'ai à dire j'ai
beaucoup de choses à dire
même si elle même si on n'aime pas ça
même si on en paiera le jour où il sera
créé je me ferai disons un peu
égratignée par
légende musique pas publics mais enfin
on peut être à la fois un homme un homme
public est aussi un homme qui a envie de
faire quelque chose pour lui puisqu'il
existe prouvez le mais qu'est-ce que je
puisse couler que je vous prouve je sais
pas moi voulait voir les partitions sa
valeur de doute et de savants gentil je
voulais vous suggérez d'anjou et
quelques mesures sur votre pierre à
moins que ce soit impossible
vous savez ceux dé 6,6
c'est très difficile quand vous voulez
que une orchestration d'opéra c'est une
orchestration au nombre de soixante et
onze musiciens pour le pupitre normal
opéra enfin j'ai pas mal alors qu'est-ce
que je fasse 71 du musicien olympienne
ok pas l'accorder c'est très difficile
plus les caire
je les vois et les interprètes mais vous
refusez de faire un essai c'est un défi
oui
d'accord
dans l'état libre d'irlande
surgie du fond
de la mer
quelques crochets quel clan y le drame
à
on fait comme une au fond
l'uni
ce n'est pas une légende lits d'aval m
ah voilà
mon
non
que le bon dieu dès dimanche m
oubli c'est jour de colère
et donne enfin sa revanche à l'île d'arz
à
je voudrais que cette oeuvre là soit une
oeuvre essentiellement populaire ce que
moi je suis un acteur populaire et
j'aime j'aime écrire pour le populaire
vous savez à la première page de la
théorie de la musique il ya la musique
et l'art des sons
ça c'est la première ligne quand lisa la
première chose que vous apprendre de
vous a pour la musique et cela m'est
toujours resté ce que j'aime dans la
musique c'est justement de la grande
simplicité c'est le dépouillement au
maximum des complications orchestrale
des effets un peu compliqué comment n'ai
je n'aime pas cette sorte de musique où
il faut une grille ou c'est à mots
croisés ou il faut où il faut je démens
il faut soit être entre les mains pour
écouter ça je n'aime pas et d'ailleurs
vous savez que très souvent la
complication d'une musique par ses
orchestrations par ses harmonies et
quitte à paraître un peu
un peu méchant ce que je dis c'est
souvent un cache misère
je suis persuadé que des musiciens
écoutant ce moment et se disent c'est
une plaisanterie parce qu'on ne fait pas
sale habitude mais c'est là où c'est
difficile justement de se dissocier
complètement quand on est un lecteur se
dissocier arrivé à on ne veut pas vous
ne voulez pas me dissocier c'est ça qui
m'énerve parce que moi je veux qu'on me
dise aussi vous semblez tellement gêné
qu'on comprend c'est très important
c'est très très très très important
c'est très important parce que parce que
je pourrais tu viens de le faire
comprenez que personne me demande de le
faire
vous étiez préparé à écrire de la
musique d'orchestre de la musique pour
un opéra en vue si vous avez une
formation classée no s'élevant ça
beaucoup de gens ne savent pas mais
n'ont pas à le savoir puisque je chante
alors ils me connaissent que souhaite
que son ce jour-là conservatoire
conservatoire
j'en suis parti d'ailleurs parce que on
n'a plus voulu de moi au bout d'un
moment et je lui ai dit moi quand je
vois toi je n'ai fait que ça je n'ai
fait que la musique depuis je suis né
j'ai tout en grosse partie tout laisser
tomber et même mes études secondaires et
tout ça au profit de la musique ce
serait un peu gaffeur de choses quand on
canton
quand on vit pour la musique elle mange
tous une grande mangeuse de temps quand
vous avez choisi définitivement est
complètement de vivre pour la musique
vos parents ont accepté facilement ce
choix au très bien ma mère surtout ma
mère était très enthousiaste
d'ailleurs je crois que l alpe
réalisions en moins ceux qui n'avaient
pas pu réaliser au auparavant
tant qu'à mon père a c'est un homme
disant plus sûr tu es la plus pratique
plus matérielles et l'estimé votre choix
était passé vous croyez pas cette
vocation
je crois qu'il ya de ça où il avait un
peu peur que cela fût tint un prétexte à
à la nonchalance et vous même vous étiez
élève au conservatoire comment imaginez
vous que ce serait votre avis les yeux
je me voyais je me voyais en pente douce
en robe de chambre à mon piano comme ça
chez moi et et travailler en simplement
je veux dire chez moi un parpaing pas de
kaya public sud écrit la musique
oui et avec l'intention de visiter
crypte avons aussi possible non il a
fallu monter sur la scène toi arrivé à
subsister
terry s'est passé ça s'est passé une
façon assez amusante par le fait que
c'était chez moi et je travaillais et je
faisais mon service militaire aussi
qu'il arrangera tout profonde profonde
et elle a atteint et qu'il fallait
absolument que je trouve quand même un
peu d'argent pour vivre parce que l'info
malheureusement pour vivre alors un
copain m'a dit pourquoi tu ne chanterai
pas les deux ou trois chansons que tu as
écrite
ça mange pas de pain c'est pas grave tu
dis oui dans le fond pourquoi pas et je
suis rentré chez moi et quand j'ai
annoncé à tout le monde que j'avais
chanté c'est cheap chine soirée
extraordinaire larry parce qu'on rit
beaucoup chez moi aussi mais quand vous
êtes rentré chez vous et que vous avez
entendu ce vaste éclat de rire ça ne
vous a pas arrêté selon fox et pas lésés
khadriya qui m'arrêtent veut pas du tout
content
non non je ne vais pas le sens du
ridicule de toute façon je ne pouvais
pas savoir ce qu'il se passe et je
voulais moi chanter uniquement tour pour
gagner mille balles quoi mais un jour
quand vous êtes retourné sur votre route
et que vous avez vu au loin très loin
les lèvres du conservatoire qu'avez vous
pensé j'ai pensé que j'avais fait du
chemin et un peu trop vite d'ailleurs
assez drôle ce que vous me poser comme
question c'est bizarre parce que
justement il y a assez peu de temps il
ya un an deux seulement que je me suis
retourné sur moi même et que je me suis
aperçu que j'avais mené une une vie de
fou enfin sans trop de contrôler tout
cela a été un peu
je t'ai projeté n'est avancée vous aviez
dévié votre route
si mais j'étais très occupé pendant
quelques années justement car ma
carrière fut si rapide que j'ai eu du
mal à me percement de ce qui m'arrive
est exactement
gilbert bécaud selon vous qu'est ce
qu'une vie réussie
je crois que l'auteur a dit qu'une vie
réussie c'est lé rêve d'enfant que l'on
réalisé à l'âge mûr non cet auteur c'est
fini je suis fait réplique alors l'opéra
que vous écrivez c'est un rêve de
jeunesse que vous en train de réaliser
oui oui c'est un rêve de jeunesse parce
que nous nous trouvons de temps en temps
un peu à l'étroit mais mes amis moi
louis amade pierre delanoë mots et
jacques emmanuel nous trouvons un peu à
l'étroit dans la chanson alors nous
avons décidé une bonne fois pour toutes
des queyries une histoire qui nous
permettait de te dire beaucoup de choses
que nous avons l'impression d'avoir
beaucoup de choses à dire encore il y à
deux baies qu un bécot qui se trouve ici
la nuit qui écrit son opéra et un autre
bécaud qui monte sur la scène et que les
gens connaissent rien à qui on demande
des autographes dans la rue
régis haslé il lui ressemble guère
mais commencer la transition
douloureusement ou tranquillement
difficilement qui a difficilement mais
pourtant malgré ces sacrifices quand
vous parlez de votre père à vous en
parler avec beaucoup d'humilité demandé
aux acteurs les autres ils vous diront
tout comme moi que c'est un le music
hall est un métier très difficile qui
vous
avant tout l'humilité je vous dire
pourquoi parce que ceux qui ne sont pas
justement humble dans le music hall ceux
qui n'ont rien compris c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas eu le temps de comprendre on
est et je vous dire pourquoi parce que
tous les soirs à chaque première comme
sont des premières et encore quand je
chante à un milan quand je jambes à rome
quand j'entends à londres quand je
chante
à new york on amérique du sud mais hier
tous les soirs on remet en question vous
comprenez alors ça ça au bout d'un
moment ce calme on comprend très bien
que être reçus à être content de ce
qu'on fait ça me ça nous même pas grand
chose il n'y a pas de faux triomphe dit
vous musicaux par armand quelquefois au
début oui il y à l'engouement du public
pour un personnage au début comme il a
été pour moi mais ensuite il faut
vraiment payé cash et le music hall
c'est un rideau un homme de musiciens et
le public et puis et puis plus rien on
n'est plus des chansons et puis le
travail et puis et puis et puis j'aime
pardon ne pas vous prenez vous n'avez
pas les acteurs de théâtre on textes des
auteurs des partenaires des accessoires
d'accessoires sont importants
l'accessoire un cendrier une cigarette
que je prends maintenant pour le doigt
une contenance devant vous cette
cigarette ans et que j'ai pas tellement
envie de la fumée mais je la gelée en
main parce que comme ça j'ai une
contenance d'ambronay et c'est en
musique que vous n'avez rien rien du
tout c'est pour ça que c'est très dur
alors on apprend très vite à être
raisonnable et cette humilité que vous
enseignez le music-hall vous l'avez
transposer dans le travail que vous
faites ici on vous savez nous on
travaille avant que tous mes pas
on travaille on sait tout ça c'est du
travail tout ça c'est beaucoup de nuits
passées tout ça ça ne s'invente pas sa
seule puis il faut le faire vite bien
mais que vous avez réfléchi au problème
de la création musicale ça se passe
comment ici ça se passe comment
c'est pas avec
et poser sa position comme question ces
potions pas répondre chien et j'ai rien
votre père années sous vos doigts de
l'inflation connaître une chanson par
exemple quand jean cocteau avait dit
gens comme toi je crois que c'est le
club qui a dit non ils ont entendu des
choses les poètes oui je les lis
beaucoup
ils ont déjà jean cocteau dit par
exemple qu'on ne pouvait pas demander
une fleur de parler peu tannique quoique
on ne peut pas demander un musicien de
parler de sa musique
si tu veux vous portez un veau gilbert
bécaud un rêve de 15 ce doit être lourd
et même parfois angoissant vous savez je
sais pas je ne sais pas si c'est
angoissant c'est tout ce que je peux
vous dire c'est comme vous me posez la
question je vais ma boîte je me faisais
pas assez sûrement gouaille sort parce
qu'on entend c'est un rêve porté si
longtemps on peut avoir peur qui au
terme et ils vous éclater dans les mains
comme un ballon oui aux chaussures
est-ce que ça ne joue pas un rôle dans
la lenteur de votre travail
non je suis bien persuadé je suis bien
persuadé que je suis un passionné que
les gens qui nous écoutent en ce moment
s'il ya quelques musiciens ces quelques
personnes qui attachent de l'importance
à la musique qu'ils aiment ça
ne prennent pas au sérieux face à paris
fait ce que je demande
la seule chose que je demande
franchement s'est dissocié de gilbert
bécaud à la série parce que toute façon
c'est pas le même temps ce serait se
tromper que de voir les mélanger
ans
on
où
et